you only have one outcome you have to  sell the business but it doesn't mean  you have to have another acquirer you  can sell the business from yourself to  yourself so if someone's going to buy  your business for a big amount of money  they're not actually going to pay for  your business right they're going to put  30 down like you do for a house and then  they're going to get a bank to finance  the rest right you have a house that you  own 100 in cash you can go to the bank  and get the 70 mortgage on your house  and just take the money in the u.s at  least tax-free and so the point is is  that in my mind two and a half years ago  the only possible outcome that i could  do to get out of pain was to sell the  thing that we build has to be sellable  that's just my conclusion it has to be  sellable or you'll eventually burn out  if you make it sellable then it actually  sits as an asset on your personal net  worth balance sheet and it continues to  provide cash flow